[موسيقى]
ما اقسى ان تفقد امام ناظريك من كنت تحلم
لهم وبهم مهما كانت بلاغه الكلمات فانها
لا تكفي للتعبير عن احزان ومشاعري من قاسى
مراره هذا الفقد يفضي لنا احمد سبسبي
وبارع صفوان واسامه التلاوي بالام لا
تكفيها بالتاكيد دقائق معدودات ويشاركوننا
قصص فقد احبائهم الذين ابتلعهم البحر
ومعهم احلامهم بحياه افضل قصصهم لا تمثلوا
الا قدرا يسيرا من فواجع عائلات الالاف
ممن سار وراء احلام الهجره الى الشمال
الاوروبي هربا من اوطان ميؤوس منها فقدوا
فيها الامن واسباب العيش الكريم فقد فيها
ومنها الامل اكثر من 25 الف مهاجر غير
نظامي وارتهم وارد احلامهم مياه البحر
الابيض المتوسط غرقا او فقدا منذ عام 2014
وفق تقارير دوليه هذه الايام نعيش اجواء
ماساه وفقت مئات المهاجرين غير النظاميين
من بينهم سوريون ومصريون وباكستانيون
قباله السواحل اليونانيه وفي فبراير
الماضي لقي قرابه 100 مهاجر غير نظامي
مصرعهم من بينهم عشرات الاطفال قباله ساحل
في جنوب ايطاليا جراء تحطم قاربهم وفي
الحادثتين كما في حوادث سابقه تصور شكوك
حول الروايات الرسميه ورغم الماسي لا
يتوقف سيل الحراقه يحرقون وثائقهم
الثبوتيه ومعها ما يربطهم باوطان لفظتهم
كما لفظهم البحر ظاهره لفتاه الانتباه
اولا في دول المغرب العربي وخصصنا لها
حلقات ثم امتدت للاسف الى دول المشرق
العربي فكلاهما في الهم سواء في قصتنا
الليله حراقه المشرق نقترب من ابعاد هذه
الظاهره مع التركيز على الشواطئ اللبنانيه
حيث تزايدت العمل الماضي اعداد الساع
الهجره غير النظاميه بحرا بمقدار ثلاثه
اضعاف مقارنه بعام 2021
في المقدمه يديهم اللبنانيون ثم
الفلسطينيون نتسلل الى كواليس عمليات
شبكات تهريب البشر عبر اثنين من عناصرها
نتساءل عن دور الاجهزه الامنيه اللبنانيه
والجهات القانونيه في التصدي لها والرد
على اتهامات التواطئ بعض افرادها نستكمل
بقيه هذه القصه مع زياده الصائغ المديره
التنفيذي لملتقى التاثير المدني الخبير في
السياسات العامه
وماتس هارلم المحامي والمستشاره القانوني
الدولي ونتعرف مع بسامه التلاوي على
تفاصيل قصته مع الهجره والتي انتهت للاسف
بماساه عائليه نساله عن الابعاد القانونيه
والسياسيه والاجتماعيه وراء تنامي ظاهره
الهجره غير الشرعيه في مناطق بعينها في
لبنان ومدى نجعت المقاربه الامنيه في
التعامل مع الظاهره وعن امكانيه توافر
بدائل امنه للهجره غير الشرعيه لكن لنشاهد
القصه اولا وبعدها الحوار
الحراقه من اقصى الشمال المغربي الى
طرابلس شمال لبنان
يحملون احلامهم على ظهورهم ويرتادون قوارب
لا تكاد تنفع لنزهه صغيره
ليخوضوا مغامره الحياه او الموت وسط البحر
المتوسط
ويجمعهم حلم واحد الحلم الاوروبي
وقد بدات الشعله الاولى للحراقه في المغرب
العربي عام 95
كنتيجه لتضييق بعض الدول الاوروبيه القيود
على المهاجرين وعرفوا تاريخيا بالحراقه
لانهم كانوا يحرقون وثائقهم عند الوصول
الى اوروبا ثم امتدت هذه الظاهره في
السنوات الاخيره الى دول الشرق الاوسط
ومنها لبنان
كان شهر رمضان نحن طلعنا انا ومرتي
ماسه ومحمد وجاد
وين ما بكون هنا معي وين ما بتطلع عن
القدامي
هلا بمشي البحر هون او هيك بعمل حالي منه
ماني شايفه
سافرت البحر سنه الماضيه مثل هالايام
هايدي ومهاجرين من هالبلد نحنا وطالعين
بالبحر دولتنا اكلتنا بقلب البحر رجعت انا
والشبان والبنتين
الامل الوحيد هو هذا البحر
بنعرف حالنا اذا طلعنا
ونفضلنا نقول وصلنا برا الامان وبنقدر
الاب المستقبل لاولادنا
[موسيقى]
رحله البحر غير المنتظمه هي منها بس وليده
الامس هي كانت عم تجرى على مر السنين ولكن
عام 2022 بالتحديد هو عام صارخ جدا
بارقامه اولا شدنا على زياده عدد الاشخاص
يلي اخذوا البحر بنسبه 3 اضعاف عن العام
اللي سبقه يعني عن عام 2021 ثانيا شهدنا
بتزايد ركاب يلي هن ركاب لبنانيين من جنس
اللبنانيه يلي صاروا عم ياخدوا البحر بشكل
اكثر
وثلاثه وهايدا امر محزن جدا شهدنا على
خسائر كثير كبيره بالارواح يعني من عام
2022 هناك ما لا يقل عن 185 شخص فقدوا
حياتهم او ما زالوا مفقودين بالبحر من بعد
ما اخذوا البحر وخطروا بحياتهم
بحسب ارقام المفوضيه الاوروبيه توزعت نسب
المهاجرين عام 2022 بين السوريين
ولبنانيين وفلسطينيين ليتصدر السوريون
النسبه الاعلى من المهاجرين
انا بالنسبه الكلاجئ سوري كموضوع النزوح
واللجوء ما حدا سائل وما حدا عنده خبر
بشيء نهائيا يعني بنحكي اليوم نحن من 2012
فبنحكي بعشر سنين 12 سنه هيدا منك كلمه
وبكون عندك عائله بدك تامني الاستقرار
اكثر لعائلتك يعني فهذا الشيء ما كان هون
موجود
عام 2012 لجا احمد وزوجته الى لبنان لينا
بنفسه عن الصراع الدائري في بلاده كما
يقول وفي بلد اللجوء لبنان رزق بثلاثه
اولاد ما في حدا اصلا روحه رخيصه عليه
واللي عم بموت على الارض
اختاري يروح ليموت بالبحر هلا بالنسبه
لسوريا انا ما فيي ارجع بسبب الاحتياط في
مشاكل امنيه تعتبر وهون انا بالنسبه لي
فقدت وراي
ورديت قدمت للامن العام ورفضوا الاقامه
واعطوني
سفر يعتبر انا هلا غير قانوني ما عندي حل
لالي قادر ارجع على بلدي وللي قادر ابقى
هون
فما عندي خيار تاني
اول شيء انا دفعت النص وبس لاوصل بعد فتره
بندفع النص الثاني ودفعت بحدود 5,500 6000
من هون من هون من هون لا قدرت اجمع هذا
الرقم
خسر احمد زوجته واطفاله وبعدها اوراقه
الثبوتيه وكل المال الذي جمعه حاله كحال
كثيرين ممن يستعينون بالمهربين للوصول الى
بلد الحلم ان وصل
سلكنا طريقنا باتجاه شمال لبنان للقاء احد
المهربين الناشطين ليخبرنا عن كواليس
عمليات التهريب غير ان ابا هارون وهو اسم
وهمي تراجع في اللحظات الاخيره وبدل
اللقاء المصور بلقاء هاتفي لدواعي امنيه
بحسب ما قال لنا
الرجل
عنده اولاد مثلا اربع خمس سنين
[موسيقى]
قطعنا فيها بالازمه الاقتصاديه بنشوف في
ارتفاع بالتوقيفات اعداد هائله يعني شوف
من خمسه خمس متورطين بالالفين سبعه بال
242 هذا بتشبه عملنا ايضا على صعيد ملاحقه
الجريمه كمان
اللي بعده عمليه الخرا الاجهزه الامنيه من
اجل انه
يقدروا العصابات المنظمه يامنوا الهجره
غير شرعيه هيدي صعبه كثير مهدتين سمع
وانعمل تحقيقات بتوقف الاشخاص ما بيبين
بالتحات انه في تعاون بهذا الموضوع
ومن المهاجرين ايضا ممن اخذوا على عاتقهم
تجهيز وتنظيم رحلاتهم دون اللجوء الى
المهربين وهذه ظاهره مستجده في لبنان
بارع صفوان استعانت باحد هؤلاء وغامرت
بحياتها مع ابنائها الاربعه عشيه الثالث
والعشرين من نيسان ابريل من عام 2022 غير
ان الماساه كانت بانتظارها وفقدت ابنتيها
وسط البحر
وليدي ما بدهم يطلع قلت له بدنا نطلع يعني
جوزي متوفي
وعندي بنتي خاطبه
مرقنا بوقت كورونا او مرقنا بازمه كبيره
وبلشنا شوي شوي بدل ما نقدم لقدام صرنا
نرجع لورا
صاحبتها باجر البيت وصار مشاكل كتير يعني
انا
لحتى بيتي تركته وما ولا ولا عزه كل شيء
ورا داري قلت ما بدي اتطلع لورايي
انا ماني طالعه هيك على العميانه انا خيي
هونيك ولد عمي هونيك وكلهم هنيك بايطاليا
بالمانيا صارن يعني صار لهم سنين ماني
رايحه انا هيك على الموت ماني عارفه شي من
شي ولا روح لا اتبهدل ولا
الشواطئ ولايجي البوليس ليحطونا لا
تعتبر السواحل التركيه احدى ابرز محطات
العبور لحراقه المشرق العربي باتجاه
اليونان او قبرص
اما المهاجرون من لبنان فقد تحولت وجهتهم
الاساسيه من قبرص الى ايطاليا في السنوات
الاخيره
[موسيقى]
رحنا 23 نيسان
وكان نهار سبت
ومشينا يعني كنا بعدنا قبل ميه الاقليميه
يعني كنا بعدنا ضمننا لبنان كان بدنا
لمياء الاقليميه بنوصل بدنا 5 دقايق
عالزبط
لم تصل بارعه صفوان وبقيه المهاجرين الى
وجهتهم الاخيره وذلك بسبب غرق قاربهم قبل
اجتيازهم للمياه الاقليميه
وبرزت روايتان مختلفتان لاسباب الحادث
الاولى ادلى بها الناجون مشيرين الى ان
مركب الجيش اللبناني تعمد الاصطدام بهم
اما روايه الجيش اللبناني فترجع سبب الغرق
الى اصطدام قارب المهاجرين بمركب الجيش
وليس العكس
ضرب اول ضربه
ضربه من ميله ورق مطرح ما انا قاعده
ما حسينا حنا نغرقنا
ضلينا شي ساعه ونص نحن بالمي بالبرد
وانا اجمل ما كنت حسي بالبرد
وما عاد عرفت شي عن اولادي اجمل ما عرفتهم
وين حتى عزمها فتحت وما حاعمل عزا علم
كتير فتحت قبور ورجعت
عدد من المحامين مطالبين باجراء تحقيق
بالقضيه للكشف عن ملابسات الحادثه ومعاقبه
المسؤولين عن غرق المركب الذي كان على
متنه اكثر من ثمانين شخصا 30 منهم ما
زالوا في عداد المفقودين بينما تم انتشال
سبع جثث فقط
وانقاذوا 45
لما صارت الماساه وخسر طرابلس اكثر من 45
ضحيه جمعنا حقنا تقريبا كنا شي 12 محامي
وتقدمنا بادعاء امام النيابه العامه
التمييزي يعني نحنا دعينا بعد ثلاثه اشهر
بدات التحقيقات بعد ما دعينا نحن كان معنا
وقائع افاده الناجين لما نزلوا من المركبه
شو صار معهم ورجعوا اكدوا الكلام بوزاره
الدفاع لكن للاسف حتى اليوم ما في اهتمام
جدي من القضاء بهذه القضيه حيصيرنا سنه
تقريبا وما زال الملف بين مديريه
المخابرات بين النيابه العامه العسكريه
اكيد انا ما بتهم الجيش كله انا يعني
محددين الاشخاص اللي حاربونا بقلب المي
واللي مجزون لمن حكم عليهم اللي ما حدا
لان نحن لازم المفروض نحضر الجلسات وقت
اللي عمله مؤتمر بالجيش هو كان لاننا نحنا
ما خلونا نفوت عليه
قائد المركب اخذ قرار
بتنفيذ مناورات
للهروب من الخافره والمركب الثاني
بشكل
ادى الى ارتطامه هو بالمركب الكبير
الخافره
وبالزورق الصغير بسبب الوزن الزائد المركب
غرق بسرعه اقل من خمس ثواني كان المركب
غرقان تحت المي وكل شيء في سترات انقاذ
موجوده على مراكزناها بالمي اللي قدرنا
طلعنا 45 شخص
بين روايه الناجين وروايه الجيش اللبناني
وبانتظار انتهاء التحقيق تبقى الاجراءات
والخطوات الاستباقيه ضروره للحد من هذه
الظاهره ومعها الحد من سقوط ضحايا جدد
عمليات الهجره غير الشرعيه نحن بنعرف
بالشتاء بتوقف تقريبا فبتبلش بالربيع
والصيف وبالتالي نحن بالاضافه العملياتنا
اليوميه المهمه من اوفياء بتتشدد اعمالنا
اول شيء الدوريات على الشواطئ البحر لا
سيما منطقه الشمال بتتكثف عمليات
الاستقصاءات والاستعلام وجمع المعلومات
وتبادل المعلومات بيننا وبين الاجهزه
الامنيه ولا سيما الجيش اللبناني عنده
اكثر تواجد عاده بالبحر او كمان البر
عبر الشواطئ اللبنانيه محصوره بالركاب
اللبنانيين او المقيمين في البلاد من
جنسيات مختلفه فحسب بل انضم اليهم ركاب
سوريون ممن عبروا الحدود البريه خلصت بهدف
الهجره حصرا
للكشف عن بعض خفايا عمليات التهريب البريه
تواصلنا مع احد المهربين في منطقه البقاع
ليزودنا بمعطيات مرتبطه بهذه الظاهره
حوالي من حوالي ثلاث سنين من 2020 حاب
تكون مصريه
من شان يقدروا يجوا من الحدود اللبنانيه
السوريه
ومن شان طلعوا عبر البحر يطلعوا على
اوروبا
ايام الربيع والصيف اقل شيء بيوصل للعدد
للثلاثين 40 شخص من كل اسبوع من معبر واحد
بيكون في تنسيق مع ناس
مع حدا من اي اجهزه امنيه
وبترتب الموضوع بيننا وبينه بيكلفني شخص
من سوريا على لبنان 100 دولار
[موسيقى]
انا عندي امل يرجع
كل شي بالبيت ما روحت
[موسيقى]
هلا العالم كلها بتستخدم فيه كيف انا بنزل
على البحر انا بقول لهم اولادي بقلب البحر
انا بروح لعندهم
بعدهم بصلي بعض بيحكي انا واولادي
تحول الحلم الاوروبي الى ماساه لكثير من
المهاجرين الناجين ولعائلاتهم بعد فقدان
ابنائهم واقاربهم غير ان هذا الحلم بقي
بالنسبه للبعض هدفا يسعون اليه خلدون عياش
خير مثال على ذلك عايشين
واربع اولاد عايش غرفه كانوا اثنين
المدرسه هالسنه ولا ولد في بالمانيا الي
حدا
ابن خالي راح تهريب كان عايش بغرفه
هو كمان عنده اربع اولاد هلا بيتصل فينا
بيفتح فيديو
بس طلع هاي
شوف البيت اللي قاعد فيه ونشوف حياته كيف
تغيرت من السماء للارض وانا اوعدك بتحصل
عن نفسي هذا شجعني اكثر
في احتمال اني افقد حياتي وحياته اولادي
بهاي وفي احتمال كمان اللي على اذا وصلت
بيموت مره واحده
بس كل يوم
[موسيقى]
في اكثر الحوادث الى من في لبنان توفي
اكثر من 100 شخص بغرق مركب قباله شواطئ
مدينه طرطوس السوريه في اواخر العام 2022
[موسيقى]
وفي العام نفسه اعلنت منظمه الهجره
الدوليه عن وفاه او فقدان اكثر من 1500
مهاجر في البحر الابيض المتوسط ليصل مجموع
الضحايا الى عتبه الخمسه وعشرين الف مهاجر
منذ العام 2014
امام هذه الارقام الصادمه هل من مستجيب
لايقاف عداد قوارب الموت
للاسف تستمر هذه الظاهره وماساه العديد من
البشر الراغبين في حياه افضل وذلك اقل
وابسط الحقوق التي يفترض ان ينعم بها
الانسان ارحب بكم مشاهدينا الكرام وبضيوفي
ايضا من بيروت زياد الصائغ المديره
التنفيذي لملتقى تاثير المدني الخبير في
السياسات العامه من اوسلو
محامد ومستشار القانون الدولي ومن بيروت
وسامه تلاوي وهو لبناني فقد زوجته واولاده
الاربعه في البحر في البحر الابيض المتوسط
قبله السواحل السوريه خلال محاولته للهجره
غير النظاميه في سبتمبر الماضي وسام نشكرك
جزيل الشكر على موافقتك اليوم للظهور معنى
نقدر ذلك مليا شهادتك مهمه جدا لمن تخالجه
ربما هذه الافكار ولمن يفكر بان هذا الحلم
لا زال ممكنا لو عادت بك الذا كره الان
قليلا الى الوراء هل كنت
لتختار نفس الطريق هل كنت لتتخذ نفس
القرار
اول شيء انا بشكركم بشكره تلفزيون الجزيره
اللي يهتم فينا وخلينا نطلع نحكي
اذا رجع فينا الزمن اكيد لا اطلع ابدا
بموت ببلدي
لانه انا متت بالبحر تلاتين
متى تقول لمن يفكر في هذا الموضوع وهم كثر
في بلاد المغرب العربي نعم لكن في المشرق
الان باتت الظاهره اكثر فاكثر ماذا تقول
لمن يفكر في هذه الطريقه بقول له انا بقول
له انه ما حدا يجرب هالطريقه بطريقه كتير
خطره
وبتمنى حدا يطلع هيك طلع لانه نحن اللي
عشناه نحن متنا الف متر
بالبحر
وطريق كتير خطير ما بتمنى حدا يطلع ابدا
ولا بنصح حدا يطلع
وسام يعني يعني ارجو ان تعذرني لكن هل
بامكانك اليوم استرجاع ما حدث في ذلك
اليوم هل بامكانك اخبار المشاهد الكريم
اللي بيرجع
لانه نحن عشنا
بتمنى حدا يطلع ابدا لان الارواحة
على اهليه
نود ان تطلع المشاهد الكريم طبعا لا احد
اطلاقا يملك يعني اطلاق الاحكام على اي
كان وحدك فقط كنت تعرف الظروف التي دفعتك
الى هذا الخيار المر لكن نتساءل حقيقه عن
ماذا دفعك الى هذا الخيار الصعب
لدفعني انه نحن عايشين ببيئه كتير
بسيطه وفقيره طرابلس
وما بقى عنا مي نطعت عنا المي والكهرباء
وصعوبه الحياه
وما في حدا يهتم فينا من الدوله ولا حدا
نظرنا يعني احنا
اخذت القرار انه انا ومرتي الله يرحمهم
انه نطلع على بلد يكون تعاملنا بانسانيه
ونعيش عيشه قريبه
قام راحوا عند ربهم سبحان الله طبعا هذه
الرحله ما كانت لتكون لولا المتاجرين في
حياه البشر هؤلاء المهربون هل لك ان تحكي
لنا عن تجربتك كيف تم التواصل مع هؤلاء هل
قدموا لكم ضمانات فيما يخص امكانيه العبور
للضفه الاخرى
اول شيء ارجونا انه
هو كان نهار اربعه ارجونا النهار الاربعه
يعني ارجونا شي واخذونا هن غدرونا
طلعونا
خمسين شخص ركبوا عليه 150 شخص
والمركبه اللي ركبونا في منه صلح اصلا
لسفر يروح على
على ايطاليا ما بيصلح يمشي خمسه كيلو متر
بالمي مركب صيد
بس
على الرحله طبعا هؤلاء المهربون هؤلاء
التجار في حياتي واحلام البشر المستثمرين
في ماسيهم طبعا هم معروفون لدى سكان
المنطقه هناك وقد تبعنا شهاده لاحدهم في
فيلم الليله قال بانه تم القاء القبض عليه
لمده 24 ساعه لكن لعدم وجود ايه ادله تم
اطلاق صراحه ماذا بالنسبه للمهربين
المعروفين لديكم هل من قصص ربما تؤكد او
ربما تنسي هل تم القاء القبض عليهم هل من
ملاحقات قانونيه تجاههم
اوكي هلا هو انكمش واحد اسمه بلال ديب
مهرب هذا محبوس
هسه عنده خيو اسمه يوسف ديب وعسكري بالجيش
اسمه عبد الله اديب بيكون سهره وابن عمه
هدول ما فلوتين هلا عم يامنوا مركبه بدهم
يطلعوا فيه
للدوله للقضاء اللبناني
هلا عم يامنوا ماركه وعم يجهزوه بدهم
يهربوا فيها على ايطاليا
من الاجهزه الامنيه
وسام طبعا ارجو ان تبقى معنا طبعا سنعود
اليك شهادتك مهمه لكل من يفكر ربما في هذا
الخيار المر لان النتيجه ستكون امر عليه
التفكير مرتين طبعا الظروف قد تكون صعبه
لدى كثيرين وليس لنا ان ننظر في هذا
الموضوع ابقى معي وسام ارجوك تحول السيد
زياد السائق وهو المدير التنفيذي لملتقى
تاثير المدني الخبير في السياسات العامه
سيد زياد قصه وسام غيرها للاسف كثير هؤلاء
المتاجرون في حياه البشر بعضهم لازال يعني
طليقا البعض الاخر كما كان يتحدث اوسام تم
القاء
القبض عليهم كيف تجري تحقيقات عاده في مثل
هذه الحوادث
بطبيعه الحال
سيدتي نحن امام ماساه على مستويات عده
ماساه
جسديه ماساه نفسيه
على المستوى الفردي ولكن ماساه مجتمعيه
الاجهزه القضائيه اللبنانيه والقوى
العسكريه والامنيه
معنيه
بوضع اليد
بشكل كامل على التحقيقات الجاريه وبالتالي
توقيف المتورطين بهذه الجريمه المنظمه من
الاتجار بالبشر وعلينا ان نعترف ان
الاشتباك الذي يقوم عاده بين اعضاء هذه
العصابات التي تمتهن الجريمه المنظمه
بتهريب البشر هي ليست فقط
شبكه مرتبطه بلبنان هي شبكه مرتبطه ما بعد
ايضا الحدود اللبنانيه وهذه مساله اساسيه
التحقيقات من الواضح انها مازالت قائمه
هناك توقيف متتالي
لاشخاص ولمجموعات مرتبطه بهذه الاشخاص
تنظم عمليه
الاشجار
بالبشر وبتهريبهم بشكل غير شرعي ولكن
علينا ان نعترف ان المقاربه الامنيه
القضائيه لا تكفي ويجب الذهاب الى معالجه
مسببات هذا النوع من الجرائم المنظمه وهذا
النوع من انسداد الافق لدى المواطنات
والمواطنين اكانوا لبنانيين او كانوا
لاجئين سوريين او لاجئين فلسطينيين او حتى
عمال اجانب لانه عدم معالجه المسببات وهي
مسببات اقتصاديه ماليه اجتماعيه او حتى
مسببات نفسيه لن تصل ابدا الى اي نتيجه في
المقاربه الامنيه القضائيه اذا قصرنا هذا
النوع من المقاربات فقط على ملاحقه
العصابات التي تقوم بهذه العمليه وهناك
مسؤوليه ايضا على من يغرر بهم للارتباط
بهكذا نوع من هجره غير نظاميه وعلى
المجتمع اللبناني ان يعي عمليا انه اذا
تورط
وسمح لنفسه بان يكون من عداد المهاجرين
غير النظاميين سيكون امام ماساه ان لم
يغرق في البحر سيكون امام ماساه عند حدود
الدوله التي سوف يفد اليها خصوصا انه
سيكون وفودا غير شرعيا نعم خاصه هذه نقطه
مهمه جدا تشير اليها السيد زياد خاصه ان
هذه الدول مع جنوحها الى اليمين المتطرف
باتت يعني تحارب هؤلاء تمنع وصولهم وحتى
من هم هناك تحاول طردهم هذه نقطه سنعود
اليها لاهميتها اتحول للسيد ماديس هارلم
يعني فيما يخص شبكات تهريب البشر سيد حارم
المتورطين فيها متعددي الجنسيات والضحايا
كذلك اشار ضيفنا الكريم سيد زياد الى ان
هناك شبكات تهريب دوليه ليس فقط لا تكون
في البلد الذي تنطلق من هذه الهجره لكن
ايضا في الضفه الاخرى نتساءل حقيقه ما فرص
تعقب هؤلاء قانونيا وماذا وكيف ينظر
القانون الدولي لمثل هذه الانشطه
هؤلاء كذلك موجودين في الدول الاوروبيه
وبامكاننا مساءلتهم كذلك واريد ان اؤكد
نعم هذه مسؤوليه المهربين لكن رجاء فلتاخذ
بنظر الاعتبار بان الدول الاوروبيه لديها
مسؤوليه كبيره في هذا الاطار ما يقومون به
فيما يخص الدفع بعيدا بالمهاجرين الدفع
بعيدا ممن يسعون للحصول على اللجوء
السياسي هذا يعتبر انتهاكا للقانون الدولي
بالتاكيد هذه مسؤوليه المهربين وكذلك
الدول الاوروبيه لديها مسؤوليه كبيره هنا
طبعا هذه الايام للاسف نعيش قد بدات بدا
بالفعل موسم الهجره الذي يمتد من الربيع
الى يعني شهور الصيف نعيش ماساه الحادث
الاليم الذي وقع قباله السواحل اليونان
هناك دائما في هذا الحادث وحتى في حوادث
اخرى تابعنا ذلك ايضا في قصه الليله اصابع
اتهام تشير الى الجهات التي تتدخل لايقاف
هذه القوارب في غرق او حتى اغراق هذه
القوارب او حتى الى اهمال من الجانب هذه
في هذه الحاله الجانب اليوناني كيف ترى
ترى عفوا فرص التحقيق في هذا الحادث فيما
يخص اليونان وحوادث سابقه هل تم التحقيق
فيها وما الذي افضت اليه
نعم هذا بالتاكيد كذلك يعتبر مسؤوليه
اليونان او اي دوله اوروبيه اخرى منوط بها
التحقيق في مثل هذه الحوادث لترى ما حدث
حقيقه على الارض بالتاكيد اعتقد ان
الضحايا هم يتضررون بسبب ذلك ولابد ان يتم
ايجاد هؤلاء الضحايا والذين تمكنوا من
البقاء على قيد الحياه مسؤوليه تقتضي ان
نبحث عن الضحايا الذين لا يزالون في عرض
البحر هذه كذلك مسؤوليه الدول الاوروبيه
هل يمكن ملاحقه هذه الحكومات والاتحاد
الاوروبي وتحميل المسؤوليه عن عدم انقاذ
المهاجرين اولا وتحقيق في محاولات من شهود
ممن نجوا بانه بالفعل كانت هناك محاولات
في اقله عدم المساعده ان لم يكن محاولات
لاغراق هذه القوارب
نعم بالطبع هذا الامر غير مقبول هذا ليس
متماشيان لا مع القوانين المحليه في
اليونان وكذلك القوانين الدوليه نحتاج الى
تحقيقات تنظر الى هذا الامر نعم هذه هي
مسؤوليه ربما خفر السواحل لكنها قد تكون
كذلك مسؤوليه السلطات حسب الظروف التي
وقعت على الارض النقطه التي اريد ان اؤكد
عليها هي اننا نحتاج الى تحقيق ونحتاج الى
تحقيق الان وهذا امر مهم جدا التحول السيد
زياد وتساءل حقيقه من وجهه نظرك ما
امكانيه
تحقيق العداله للضحايا عمليات غرق القوارب
في البحر الابيض المتوسط وقباله الشواطئ
الاوروبيه
لا ادري اذا كان الكلام عن تحقيق
العداله في ماساه
فقدنا فيها ارواح
هو واقعي في عمليا نحن فقدنا
ارواحا هؤلاء امام المسؤولياتهم صحيح ان
الفقد لا يمكن ان يعوض باي طريقه
حتما لا يمكن تعويض الفقد هذا محاوله ان
اقوله ولكن
محاسبه
المسؤولين عن هذه الجريمه المنظمه ايضا
يجب ان تنطلق من مسار شراكه اورو متوسطيه
بطبيعه الحال بما يعني التعاون في بناء
سياسه عامه متكامله بين ضفتي البحر الابيض
المتوسط على المستوى القانوني بهذا المعنى
لا يمكن ان تقصر التحقيقات على المستوى
المحلي فقط في لبنان بل يجب ان يذهب لبنان
باتجاه فهم طبيعه
العصابات التي ترتكب هذه الجريمه المنظمه
وبمن هي مرتبطه في الضفه الاخرى وهذا
يقتضي التبادلا للمعلومات مع الدول التي
كان هؤلاء الضحايا يتوجهون اليها في هذه
القوارب من ناحيه
ومن الضفه الاخرى ايضا يجب ان نذهب باتجاه
تعقب عصابات هذه الجريمه المنظمه وبالتالي
اقامه مناظره مباشره بين طرفي هذه الجريمه
المنظمه معا وبالتالي تفكيك شبكات الاتجار
بالبشر والهجره غير النظاميه في البحر هذا
التنسيق الاورو متوسط غائب حتى الان اكان
على المستوى العماني او اكان على المستوى
القانوني والمطلوب ان يبدا ان يبادر
الاتحاد الاوروبي وايضا الدول الذي يخرج
منها هؤلاء بالبحث معا في مسار تنسيقي
متكامل على المستوى العملاني لضبط الحدود
من ناحيه ولكن على المستوى القانوني
لتفكيك وضبط هذه الشبكات وتحويلها الى
المحاكمه
الى لبنان تحديدا الاعداد وفق ما تبعناها
في قصتنا الليله رقم واحد هم من السوريين
السوريين مقسمون الى قسمين التعبير من هو
لاجئ في لبنان وهناك من يشير باصابع
الاتهام للمحرضين على هؤلاء
اللاجئين الموجودين مما ربما يضيق عليهم
العيش فبالتالي يفكرون في الهجره الى
الضفه الاخرى والسوريون القادمون من داخل
السوري وقد تابعنا تابعنا شهاده لاحد
المهربين يتحدث عن عشرات اسبوعيه يدخلون
من سوريا بغرض الهجره من يسهل لهؤلاء ما
الذي يمكن ان يقال في هذا الموضوع
هناك حدود بين لبنان وسوريا غير مضبوطه
ومن الاجدى بدء البحث في هذه المساله لضبط
الحدود البريه والتي يمكن ان يتسلل منها
عصابات تنظم دخول هؤلاء اللاجئين السوريين
الذين
يريدون الانتقال من سوريا الى دوره ثالثه
عبر لبنان اما فيما اسميته بين مزدوجين
حملات التحريض علينا ان نعترف ان القوارب
التي خرجت من لبنان حملت لبنانيين وسوريين
وفلسطينيين وحتى جنسيات اخرى معا بهذا
المعنى علينا الاضاءه اكثر على انسداد
الافق لدى هؤلاء اللاجئين ولد الشعب
اللبناني ولكن ايضا التغرير بهم على قاعده
ان ما ينتظرهم في الضفه الاخرى هو مساله
ورديه وقد نجح البعض للاسف هناك تجارب
نجحت في الهجره غير الشرعيه ونقح حاولت
نقل هذه العدوى الى الاصدقاء
والاقارب ان لم نعالج مسببات هذه لجنه غير
الشرعيه سنبقى في مقاربه العوارض وهذا لن
ينفع وكل المقاربات الامنيه هي مقاربات
مبتوره اما تفكيك شبكات
العصابات لهذه الجريمه المنظمه فهي مساله
اشد تعقيد تعقيدا وهي المساله الذي يجب
العمل عليها اكثر خصوصا في اطار تنسيق
اورو متوسطي وقضائي فقط للتوضيح يعني
حملات التحريض ليس مصطلحا لي انا هو للاسف
مصطلح تم تداوله ولا شك الجميع يتفق بان
السوري او اللبناني الانسان العربي في
الضفه الجنوبيه هو جميعه ضحيه للاسف
لممارسات تدفعه لان يرمي بنفسه واولاده في
الذات كبده وعائلته في البحر اعود مره
اخرى للسيد حالم السيد زياد اشار الى نقطه
مهمه وهي ضروره تنسيق بين الطرفين
نتساءل حقيقه ما تقييمك لمدى فاعليه
التعاون بين السلطات في دول جنوب المتوسط
والدول في الضفه الاخرى وايضا خاصه
المنظمات الدوليه المعنيه بقضايا اللاجئين
والهجره التي لديها لديها لا شك دور في
هذا الموضوع
في بديل الامر اريد ان نؤكد نعم بالتاكيد
لابد ان يكون هناك تنسيق لكن اريد ان اعود
الى النقطه اخرى عندما نتحدث عن المهاجرين
غير القانوني من الضروري ان نتذكر كذلك
هناك اشخاص يسعون للحصول على اللجوء
السياسي هؤلاء ليسوا مهاجرين غير قانونيين
والدول الاوروبيه مسؤوليتها تقتضي بان
يحظى هؤلاء الاشخاص بحق اللجوء هذا ما لا
يحدث حاليا هم يحاولون الدفع بهم بعيدا
الى دول المنشا او الدول التي انطلقوا
منها وهنا تكمن المشكله الاساسيه نعم نعم
اتفق بشان الاشياء التي تمت اثارتها
والمرتبطه بالمهربين لكن لابد ان لا ننسى
مسؤوليه الدول تجاه الاشخاص الذين يسعون
للحصول على اللجوء السياسي وهذه المسؤوليه
تضعهم امام امام ايه
يعني خطواتي يجدر الدفع بها للقيام بها
امام هؤلاء الهاربين في كثير من الاحيان
كما هو الحاله السوريه ربما من وضع امني
وسياسي يهدد حياتهم
سيف ذو حدين نعم هناك بعض المهربين الذين
يلعبون دورا كبيرا لكن هناك بعض الاخر
الذين يساعدون الناس للحصول على اللجوء
السياسي في دوله اخرى اذا ما الذي يجدر
بالدول الاوروبيه ان تقوم به النعم يجدر
بها ان تعمل وان تنسق وان تناهض الجريمه
المنظمه لكن يجدر بها ان تجد سبيلا لتتاكد
من احضر احضى الناس بحقوقهم حق اللجوء
وهذا يبدا بعمليه الانقاذ والتاكد من ان
هؤلاء الاشخاص سيتم انقاذهم من عرض البحر
وليس ابقائهم في عهد البحر ما حدث في
اليونان غير مقبول تماما ولابد ان يتوقف
هذا الامر ويتوقف الان سيد زياد في عجاله
لو تكرمت كيف تقيم انت التعاون بين
السلطات اللبنانيه
ومنظمات دوليه كمنظمه الهجره مثلا الدوليه
وغيرها من جهه الدوليه في مجال مكافحه
الهجره غير الشرعيه
افتتاح ورشه قانونيه متكامله لاتخاذ
التدابير وايضا تحسين
الاجراءات القانونيه تجاه اولا مرتكبي هذه
الجريمه المنظمه لمعاقبتهم وثانيا تحسين
شروط التعامل مع المهاجرين غير الشرعيين
والتمييز بينهم وبين طالبي اللجوء السياسي
اود ان اختم معك طبعا
ان كان يشق عليك ذلك فنحن نتفهم لكن ان
كنت ان تقدم شهادتك للمشاهد الكريم عما
حدث ذلك اليوم كيف غرق هذا القارب ما
الظروف التي كانت محيطه بكم هل بامكانك
استرجاع ما حدث ذلك اليوم
طلعونا بثلاث طفليق واخذونا على مركب بنص
البحر نحن المركبه اللي بنص البحر ما
شايفينو
طلعنا في لينا مكسر وجينا بدنا نرجع ما
خلونا نرجع كان في عصابه هيدا خيو المفروض
للمجرم اللي طلعنا
هلا مفلته اسمه يوسف ديب
ما خلونا نرجع وطلعنا بقلبه
المركبه شوي شوي ويرجع يطفي يعني منو مؤهل
لرحله على ايطالي
وصار الموجه يخبط فيه لما طفى
وغرق المركب خلال خمس خمس دقايق كان في شي
100 150 قتيل
انا كان معي اربع اولاد وامهم الله يرحمهم
في ولدين وامه دغري توفوا ما شفتهم وولدين
اخذني الموج
ضليت وفي شبسه قعدني اسمه جهاد
فلسطيني من بيروت
ساعدني رياض جبتهم استرجعتهم وضليتهم
الله اخذها امانته
وانا قلت ثلاثه ايام بالمي ووصلت على
سوريا
بس هو هو نحنا غرقنا بالمياه الاقليميه
اللبنانيه
ونشدنا الاجهزه ونشدنا وما كان حدا يرد
علينا
بوقتها ولما طلعنا من البحر رحنا الصبح
على وش الصبح
يعني طلعنا ولا حدا سائل يعني ما كانه كان
في شيء يعني ما حدا قرب علينا ولا ابدا
ابدا
وهلا عم يجهزوا
عالم كمان محاصرين عندهم مصاري وبدهم
يطلعوا فيه
انا بنجد كل شريف اذا بيمنع هاي الرحله
بتطلع او اي قاره بيطلع لانه في اطفال
وانا احترق قلبي على اربع اولاد وامهن
الله يحرق قلب حدا
وما بتمنى حدا يطلع هيك طلعه ابدا ابدا
لانه كتير طلعه صعبه كانت وانا ثلاثه ايام
بالمي يعني الله عيشني انا مت وعشت
بس هلا هن المجرمين
دوله بتهتم بموضوعنا كرمال ما يكونوا في
ضحايا بسببهم
وتهتم وقلنا ثقه بالقضاء بس يحرك لنا
هالموضوع لنشوف انه نحن لوين رايحين فيه
لانه اسا بيجينا تهديدات منهم وكلام وكثير
يعني ماساه من هيك الموضوع اللي صار معنا
طبعا السيد وسام نقدر كثيرا هذه الشهاده
التي هي للتاريخ ولن تذهب اتمنى ذلك ان
تجد الاذان الصاغيه لكل من يفكر في هذا
المر طبعا رسالتك التي وجهتها للسلطات لان
الماساه على اكثر من مستوى نتمنى ايضا ان
تصل بدايه الحل ربما يكون بالقاء القبض
على هؤلاء المجرمين المتاجرين في حياه
البشر
وبعدها ربما هذه الحكومات تبدا في التفكير
في يعني شعوبها وتحسين حياتهم وتلك قصه
اخرى قد تكون لها بقيه اشكر جزيل الشكر
السيد وسام التلاوي الذي نعبر عن تضامننا
الكامل معه ومع كل الضحايا وهو لبناني فقد
زوجته واولادها الاربعه في البحر المتوسط
قبلت السواحل السوريه خلال محاوله للهجره
غير النظاميه في سبتمبر الماضي كما اشكر
جزيل الشكر السيد زياد الص ائغ المديره
التنفيذي لملتقى تاثير المدني الخبير في
السياسه العامه ضيفنا الكريم من بيروت كما
اشكر من اوسلو المحامي ومستشار القانون
الدولي مات حالا
ختام حلقتنا هذه لنا بقيه لقصه جديده
الاثنين القادم باذن الله دمتم في رعايه
الله والسلام عليكم
[موسيقى]